playa del carmen station balnéaire
réputée pour ses plages et ses récifs de
corail est une destination prisée par
les touristes durant la période
hivernale
mais une fusillade cette fois ci au
complexe hôtelier cette étoile et
scarlett au sud de cancun et assombrir
le portrait le principal suspect et
canadien il a fait feu sur les trois
victimes hier après midi à l'intérieur
d'un restaurant de l'hôtel les trois
victimes aussi des canadiens ont été
transportés à l'hôpital où deux d'entre
eux sont morts des suites de leurs
blessures ils auraient tous des
antécédents criminels liés notamment au
trafic d'armes et de drogue le tireur
était aussi connu des policiers les
autorités mexicaines ont d'ailleurs
relayé sa photo sur les réseaux sociaux
et demeure toujours à sa recherche
affaires mondiales a réagi à l'incident
les agents consulaires se disant
communication avec les autorités locales
et se tiennent prêts à fournir toute
forme de soutien
le mexique est l'eau des pays les plus
dangereux au monde avec une moyenne de
91 meurtres par jour
en novembre 1,6 yade avait fait deux
morts sur la plage porto morelos près de
cancun et à la fin octobre deux
touristes un blogueur californien et un
allemand ont été tués alors qu'ils
avaient été pris entre les feux croisés
de trafiquants de drogue ici gabriel pro
radio canada montréal